the girag an experience yeah case you
haven't noticed some knowledge on
American and I do only anime and I never
taken a course in Asian American Studies
but I would love to teach for you indeed
it's why and by the time I was done with
the pitch about history or philosophy of
martial arts they were like yeah you're
a hired let's go the way okay now why
would they didn't want you to be Asian
because you're teaching about an Asian
subject I mean they don't want you to it
kind of works that way because of the
way you know most of the people who
stick taking a bunch of classes in
ethnic studies usually people who are
from that particular ethnic group in
fact I'm kind of people always look at
me like huh what's going on here because
I do teach in an American Indian studies
Department I have taught in an Asian
American Studies department but when you
look at everybody else usually there are
people who are from that particular
ethnic group who are passionate enough
to dig in that much to be in that field
is there an issue there like push back
if you not I mean it's kind of to be
fair people have been really cool about
it because I mean I've even had the
situation where I taught as part of an
ethnic ethnic studies class where they
were like four people right and there's
the African American Studies guy is an
African American guy in the chicken a
Latino Chicano Latino and and that was
the odd one out right I was teaching the
American Indian study section and
they're like hi you just replaced my
friend the native lady who the [ __ ] are
you I gotta kind of thing right but you
know the thing was they want to check
you and then once I did my thing the
first few lessons they were like no he's
cool we like him it's all good and then
there was no [ __ ] and like I would
have expected to run into a lot more
pushback there really wasn't one thing
in your favor about when it comes to
martial arts although it is mostly Asian
and origin it vary so widely yes Chinese
martial arts Japanese Korean I mean it
goes on and on Thai there's so many
different styles yeah and then of course
South America once Brazilian Jujitsu got
into the mix of course they in my
opinion have revolutionized martial arts
more than any other group I think that
one part of the country in South America
in Brazil they had more of an impact on
martial arts I think than anyone
because they essentially started I mean
they started the Ultimate Fighting
Championships just to see if their
martial art was superior yep and they
proved it to be so at least on its own
by by itself yeah at first you know
before everybody knew about it
I think that stuff was there's the whole
period from when Japanese martial arts
were kind of crashing because nobody was
dressing as a samurai anymore you know
doing that stuff didn't make sense
anymore and jiu-jitsu was seen kind of
as low class activity for gangsters and
you know there was less and less
popularity for that field and then when
jigoro kano the creator of judo started
he was this nerdish upper-class guy but
he was very passionate about judo so he
transformed the jujitsu curriculum into
judo
give it a whole new spin he's like no
it's not this thing to beat people up
like all the tags you have seen so far
we're using Jude was a form of Education
and I know that yeah it's a super cool
story and then he starts sending people
all over the world to spread it and so
they go to Rush and then mix with
Russian thing and they create [ __ ] and
then come out here and then with
Brazilian jiu-jitsu when Maya goes down
to Brazil and all of that so it's like
that whole story how it spins is awesome
and then you end up with the joy of
globalization where like when you see
like who is going to fighting a Sakura
and um you know Brazilian dude trained
in what originally was an Asian martial
arts transformed into this Brazilian
thing wearing Aggie going against aku
was more of a catch wrestler with
studied more through Western wrestling a
whole lot he was hilarious it's like you
have the Japanese guy was a more Western
wrestling back yeah but it's funny that
is crazy
the Japanese especially Sakuraba were
way influenced by catch wrestling which
is American folk style wrestling yeah
yeah now I didn't know that that
jiu-jitsu was used by thugs yeah that
was the part of the reason why when
Japan ration in popularity is because he
used to be sort of the samurai arts
right you do that stuff but then the
samurai and that you know by the 1870s
or so that was the collapse of the
samurai so there really wasn't a
function for this stuff anymore is like
and the only people who trained
we're mostly gangsters and kind of rough
guys who train for because they got into
fights on the street and then Cano
because he was this kind of sickly child
they put him in to strain in jiu-jitsu
to build him up give me some strength
and he was a complete nerd but he loved
jiu-jitsu and so he's like no no no
don't put it down it's a great art for
other reason and he had his own way of
spinning it around saying that was the
old stuff yeah to beat people up what we
do today is a form of Education is a
relationship with your body any
basically invented a new function for it
so that Japanese society went oh [ __ ] we
can still do that stuff and now there's
a better reason for it that's fitting
the times that's not the same reason why
we would train in the 7900 these
actually fit the context of our time
okay let's do judo and then do they have
texts where you can see the techniques
or where you could see what similarities
yeah yeah there are both inch in
jiu-jitsu manuals where there are you
know the drawings and stuff Lynette and
then by the time Cano comes around they
even start having footage after a while
right footage of actual films yeah of
utilization a tale or drills they look
goofy as hell because they are sped up
and they move money and stuff but they
yet there's great stuff and some of
those guys are just badasses from day
one I mean some of the old judo guys
they got the reputation for just being
killers yeah well for sure judo I don't
I wonder how much jiu-jitsu has changed
since then to now because obviously in
putting so much emphasis on the ground
the Brazilians really refined all the
submission techniques to a razor-sharp
edge and really changed a lot of the
original setups and the way people enter
into submissions I would love to see
what it used to look like even that's
funny because if you look at like some
old Judah like cousin Judah where they
have is very ground oriented those guys
do leg locks like you see these Japanese
guys from the 1920s like lock in each
other
and you're like oh my god so the stuff
that today is hot some of these guys
were doing and it probably wasn't as
refined but it was like man they were
doing it that's that's wrestling Katrin
was all about like what exactly they
were like locking when you know
Americans were really into Brazilian
Jujitsu and stuff is this what he got
here Jaime 1600 ad the history of
jiu-jitsu or Yawara huh Wow they dressed
up in like Aikido kimonos with the big
flowing pants and the guys like doing
some weird sort of wristlock go-go pit
stops crawling go right up there what
was it like yeah it looks like yeah he's
at least looking and getting yeah yeah
interesting and then the other one it
looks like he's got looks like he's
setting about full nelson
yeah he has a half nelson on one side
and he's got an underhook in the other
side yes you know yeah probably gonna
spin around and slam him right on his
face yeah crazy that they have you get
to look at it in these images or they
were just trying to figure out like
what's the best way to manipulate the
body mm-hmm it's just amazing to me how
much of it came from Japan yep I mean
Japan so many interesting techniques and
that one area was so vital and so
important when it came to the
development of martial arts Japan is
that weird like the story between China
and Japan is very similar to ancient
Greece and ancient Rome you know a lot
of the developments came from Greece a
lot of the developments came from China
but then both the Roman and Japanese
took those ideas and then ran with it
and systematize them gave them a lot
more of a structure game and made them
way easier to learn and to teach
yeah and then popularize them as a
result and it was like yep
now this stuff works it's a lot easier
sting to that they brought it to other
countries mm-hmm
yeah that was part of China's vision
because Khanna was not a nationalist he
did not have this Japan [ __ ] you
everybody else he had this idea of like
it is universal brotherhood of mankind
so we need to bring our stuff so that
everybody can benefit from it and and so
he sent yeah these are people all over
the world that's amazing
[Applause]